today on the matt walsh show president
biden attempts one of the most
tyrannical power grabs in the history of
the presidency issuing a vaccine mandate
that affects 100 million americans
potentially i'll have plenty to say
about that today also on the same day
that the president tried to force 100
million americans
to inject a substance into their body
camille harris got in front of cameras
to speak about the need for bodily
autonomy so there seems to be a bit of a
disconnect there and the left comes to
the defense of a death row inmates
claiming that pro-lifers are hypocrites
if they don't do the same is it true
that pro-lifers have an obligation to
oppose the death penalty we'll talk
about that plus a woman says that she's
the victim of fat phobia and racism
because she was kicked off a plane for
not wearing a shirt we'll try to sort
through that
important controversy today
along with much more on the matt wall
show
you know as we move into fall and at
least in in tennessee the weather
finally because i can actually emerge
from my house again because i won't
immediately melt as soon as i walk
outside uh and the weather gets a little
bit better like how do you want to be
spending your time do you want to spend
it outside maybe going for a hike doing
what you want to do or do you want to
spend it walking aimlessly around the
auto parts store i think i know the
answer and that's why you need
rockauto.com rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store
looking for what you want and the thing
is the select the selection isn't going
to be great the prices are going to be
terrible
and uh you're not not going to find what
you want probably anyway they're going
to have to order it online cut out the
middleman just go to rockauto.com
rockcott.com always offers the lowest
prices possible they're not gonna change
the prices uh they're gonna give you the
lowest possible price so if you get it
at rockauto.com you know you got the
best price anywhere they're a family
business they've been serving auto part
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts for from hundreds of manufacturers
um the catalog is unique and uh
remarkably easy to navigate so again go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and write walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
you know for four years we were warned
incessantly that
president donald trump was a vicious
power mad tyrant
a fascist dictator he was hitler
incarnate an authoritarian megalomaniac
etc you know we heard this over and over
and over again for four years meanwhile
in reality trump was you could argue
among the least tyrannical presidents
we've ever had
and whether you like him or you don't
like him you should be able to agree
with that um because in fact one of his
greatest flaws in my opinion was his
reluctance to use the legitimate
authority of his office in order to
enact his agenda
so his flaw was on the other end of that
spectrum entirely trump was no autocrat
at all
he was something close to the opposite
of that
uh no
we had to elect joe biden this frail
decrepit old mr magoo with a moldy
cantaloupe for a brain to see what
autocracy really looks like this is what
it looks like
so at around 5 pm yesterday only an hour
before his bedtime
biden stood in front of cameras and
unveiled his plan to defeat kovitt now i
should say he unveiled his uh his latest
plan to defeat covet he's already
implemented several other plans which
apparently came to nothing
you may recall when he first entered
office and he said that he was going to
vanquish the virus in 100 days
originally it was supposed to be 15 days
and and you know then a year later we
were still in the 15 day period and he
said well never mind it's going to be
100 days in 100 days we're going to be
through this we're going to be we're
going to defeat it
july 4th is the is the time
but 100 days 15 days came and went 100
days came and went the virus is still
with us and that is because
the virus will always be with us we live
in a world where khovit 19 exists
and will likely always exist
and all we can do is learn how to live
alongside it
that's the reality but it's a reality
that nobody in a position of authority
will publicly admit there's too much
power too much power to be gained in the
the promise of eradicating the virus
even if it's a false promise
and that promise creates for the tyrant
this kind of perfect mixture of false
hope and also fear which is a very
potent recipe
a recipe that's far too alluring for a
guy like joe biden that's what brings us
to his latest covet action plan
the president began
last night by expressing his frustration
with the americans who have chosen not
to get the vaccine listen
even as the delta variant 19
has covered 19 has been hitting this
country hard
we have the tools to combat the virus
if we can come together as a country and
use those tools
if we raise our vaccination rate protect
ourselves and others with masking
expanded testing and identify people who
are infected
we can and we will
turn the tide on covet 19.
it'll take a lot of hard work
it's going to take some time
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free
he's a very angry man joe biden is
that's always been an underrated aspect
of joe biden just how angry
he is it and not only because of his his
old age and dementia but he's he's
always been like this actually
um
and that really that's coming through
more and more just how angry he is at
everybody and especially at americans
and or he says frustrated
he's frustrated with us
why is he frustrated well because he
says
unvaccinated americans
the unclean the lepers
are posing a threat to vaccinated people
here he is explaining that
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated in
businesses all across america
my plan will extend the vaccination
requirements
that i previously issued in the health
care field uh now we're going to circle
back as as his white house likes to say
we're going to circle back to that point
in just a moment we're going to circle
back to all of this stuff but i want to
run through some of these clips first
let's let's listen as supreme leader
biden explains exactly how he plans to
force this drug into 100 million arms
we must increase vaccinations among the
unvaccinated with new vaccination
requirements
with nearly 80 million eligible
americans who have not gotten vaccinated
many said they were waiting for approval
from the food and drug administration
the fda
well last month the fda granted that
approval
so the time for waiting is over
this summer we made progress through the
combination of vaccine requirements and
incentives as well as the fda approval
four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers with 100 or
more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
and then finally what about governors
who believe in you know silly things
like
states rights
and may attempt to defy biden's royal
edicts
well he says
he's simply going to get them out of the
way listen
if they'll not help if these governors
won't help us beat the pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
doesn't explain how he's going to get
them out of the way just he's just going
to get them out of the way
because they don't matter states rights
that doesn't matter to him
at all now the president also called for
more kids to get vaccinated and he said
he was going to double the fines for
travelers on airplanes who don't wear
masks initially again he said we'd have
to mask for 100 days
of his presidency
but we're way past 100 days now and he's
not only not taking the masks away but
he's doubling the fines for people who
don't wear them
if it's not obvious by now
that the time frames these people give
us mean nothing at all
and that they only give us the time
frames because they still refuse to come
out and say it's going to be like this
forever get used to it then then i i
don't know what else to say if that's
not obvious by now
well i can think of a few additional
things to say about all this so let's go
through them let's go through all these
points
number one
all of this
makes no sense if the vaccine works
right biden says that the unvaccinated
are putting the vaccinated in harm's way
his message seems to be the vaccines
work and you should trust them
but if you don't get the vaccine then
vaccinated people will get sick and die
and it will be your fault
so get the vaccine because it works
and because other people are vaccinated
and they'll die if you don't get
vaccinated too
even though the vaccine works
and is effective
and that's why you should get it
so you don't kill other people who are
vaccinated
the messaging seems a little bit
confused to say the least
now you can't make this any less
confused by simply saying that well the
vaccine isn't 100 effective
we know that it's not 100 effective no
vaccine is 100 effective
but
if the unvaccinated still pose such a
significant threat to the vaccinated
that these kinds of sweeping unheard of
unprecedented economy-crushing policies
are necessary then that would seem to
indicate that the vaccine isn't just
imperfect it's not just not 100
uh but it's in fact nearly worthless
i'm not saying it's worthless
i'm saying that the biden administration
is sending the message that the vaccines
are worthless
the fact is this if the vaccine provides
significant protection to the vaccinated
then you can't justify mandates in the
name of protecting the vaccinated
because they're already protected
but if a vaccine does not provide
significant protection
or if we don't know whether it provides
significant protection then you also
can't justify the mandates because
you're mandating a significantly
ineffective drug
there's no way around this problem
so biden just ignores it that's his way
around it
he also ignores something else
point my second point is he's ignoring
continuing to ignore
natural immunity
we're not taking that into account at
all
the people in charge of containing the
virus have remained committed to
pretending that natural immunity doesn't
exist that it's some kind of conspiracy
theory
the research shows very clearly that
prior infection brings
robust immunity
maybe more robust than the vaccine
which means that millions of
unvaccinated people are potentially more
immune and therefore less of a public
health threat quote unquote than
vaccinated people
this is not a small point
you know if you're a vaccinated person
and you're feeling high and mighty and
looking at the unvaccinated
people and saying oh you're causing all
these problems you're a danger
for millions of the people in that
unvaccinated category
there's a very good chance you are a
greater threat than them
if they have natural immunity
again it's not a small point
this mandate forces the vaccine on
millions of people who according to the
best available science
um don't need it
that's not to say all of the
unvaccinated people have natural
immunity
but logic would tell us that millions of
them do
it is forcing an unnecessary drug
therefore into the bodies of people who
again don't need it according to the
science
if anyone still has any doubt about you
know all of this being really just a
plot to control people and not about
protecting people
this this point right here should cure
you of any doubts
there is no reason to ignore natural
immunity no good public health reason
other than the fact that from the
government's perspective there's no
control there's no power to be gained
from natural immunity and that's why
they ignore it
also the the unvaccinated slash
vaccinated dynamic the simple separation
of the two groups with no further
nuances or considerations
creates the perfect kind of tribalistic
villainization for our leaders to
exploit
joe biden last night when you if you
watched that speech and you saw some of
it in the clips that we played there
he showed more anger and disgust towards
the unvaccinated
than he ever showed towards the taliban
listen to these people talk about the
taliban
we play the secretary of state yesterday
saying yeah they're
their background is a little bit
troubling
or it's a they have a they have a
challenging background
we want them to be more inclusive
compare that to what they're saying
about unvaccinated people
because he has set the unvaccinated up
as the fall guys everything's their
fault
they're to blame for everything
this he's not the first tyrant to do
this this is a this is a tactic common
to
all tyrants throughout history
which brings us to the third and most
important point i think number three
biden does not have the authority
to do
almost any of this
despite what his actions imply he is not
king he's not a holy emperor
he's a politician
and this is still the united states of
america
he knows he doesn't have the authority
just as he knew he didn't have the
authority when he extended the eviction
moratorium he said he didn't have the
authority but he did it anyway
everyone's asking what's his legal
justification what's his constitutional
justification for doing this well i'll
tell you what his what his
legal and constitutional justification
is
uh he he said is that he can do it
because he wants to do it
and he can do it
and he will do it
and what are you going to do about it
that says legal argument
that's the justification and it's
important to understand that
it's important to understand that
because the only remedy here is defiance
americans have to look back at these
petty despots and say
no
we won't comply arrest us all
send the army in
and shut down all these businesses that
are not enforcing your vaccine mandate
we're calling your bluff
this is uh this is a time to choose it's
for this is a time for drawing lines
it's a time to say no you know the word
no has left our vocabulary in this
culture in recent years we have to
reintroduce it now
civil disobedience refusal
say no
that's the only way forward
for too long we've been you know
waiting for permission
to be free people in a free country
we've been sitting back and waiting
for our rulers to tell us okay you can
be free
now but it doesn't work that way
if you want to have a free country you
you grant your own permission
that's how it works
and we have to realize that now
before it's too late
now let's get to our five headlines
look if you have people that depend on
you then you have a real responsibility
to have
life insurance it's not something that
we like to think about but
that that's the truth this is a
responsibility that you have the people
who depend on you and here's the good
news although life insurance is not a
fun thing to go try to find or to talk
about policy genius makes it a whole lot
easier they make it easier to quote easy
to compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place
why should you compare well you could
save fifty percent or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save thirteen
hundred dollars or more per year on life
insurance by using policy units to
compare policies the license experts at
policy genius work for you not for the
insurance company so you can trust them
to help you navigate every step of the
shopping and buying process that kind of
service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google getting started is
easy first head to trust to uh
policygenius.com and in minutes you can
work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and you can compare
the quotes and you can get what you're
looking for without all the red tape and
all the hassle it's as easy as that so
head to policygenius.com right now to
get started policy genius when it comes
to insurance it's nice to get it right
well i'll start with this just to show
you how little respect these people have
for our intelligence mere hours before
biden announced his vaccine mandate
forcing a drug into the bodies of a
hundred million people all at once um
here's what camilla harris was saying
listen to this
the president and i are unequivocal
in our support of roe v wade
and the constitutionality
of roe v wade
and the right of women to make decisions
for themselves with whomever they choose
about their own bodies
and needless to say the right of women
to make
decisions about their own bodies is not
negotiable
the right of women to make decisions
about their own bodies is their decision
it is their body
these people are
totally shameless
this was
the same day this was a couple of hours
before joe biden got up there and said
you have to take the vaccine
or we're going to take your job away
from we're going to take everything from
you
she's saying uh
and and as always very eloquent from
camille harris by the way she says the
right of women to make decisions about
their own bodies is not negotiable the
right of women to make decisions about
their own bodies is their decision it's
their body
okay
the right to make a decision is their
decision
that clarifies that
but you have the right to make decisions
with your own body
they are
advancing that at the same time
you know it's it's not even like there's
a separation here of um
well we talked about the abortion thing
last month and uh now we're talking
about vaccine mandates and forget about
what we said a month ago
we're used to seeing that from democrats
and from the left
but in this case they're doing it at the
same time
you have the right to make decisions
with your about your own
body uh but here's this drug even if you
don't need it put it into your body
there is no way to make that not a a
blatant contradiction
especially because
the right to make decisions with your
own body
that is an argument
that that only applies to the vaccine
issue
and not the abortion issue
because as i've said a million times
with abortion the point is you're not
it's
it's not your body you're making a
decision about
you're making a decision to destroy to
directly
intentionally destroy someone else's
body
this is a
you are acting upon someone else's body
and destroying it so it's not about your
body
but with the vaccine it is it's
the only body directly
affected is your own
so that applies that logic actually
applies the bodily autonomy argument
is a bad argument
in many of the contexts that the left
uses it especially abortion just doesn't
apply at all to abortion
but here is one area
probably the the
primary area where it actually does
apply
just to vaccines
and i i know what the response is i know
the response is
yeah but if you don't get the vaccine
then then you you could get someone else
sick
but even if even if that's true like if
we're again pretending or if we're
just
ignoring the issue of national natural
immunity
and if we're doing this weird thing
where we want to force the vaccine but
at the same time we're acting like the
vaccine doesn't work at all so that you
still pose a threat to vaccinated people
even putting all of that craziness aside
it's still indirect
okay by by not getting a vaccine
you are not directly murdering anybody
i know that that's the way that people
in power have been talking about this
issue for a year and a half now
that to not get a vaccine or to walk out
of your side without outside without a
mask on it's tantamount to directly
killing someone but it's at but it's not
okay you're not directly harming anyone
that's not your intention in doing it
you know even if someone is harmed if
there's there's many degrees of
separation
as opposed to abortion where it is a
direct act
upon someone else's body to destroy it
that difference is not insignificant it
really matters
all right
let's uh move since we're on the
pro-life issue a death row inmate named
um
john ramirez had his execution halted by
the supreme court on wednesday night
because
he claimed that his religious freedom
was violated if his pastor was not able
to lay hands on him as he was being
executed which apparently is not
something that they allow in texas i
think they allow
i don't know what the rule is exactly
but they allow the pastor in there but
no one is allowed to
make physical contact with the uh with
the condemned as they are being executed
but he said this is a violation of his
religious liberty so the supreme court
came in and they halted it and this is
going to go through the courts again and
then you know um
uh but before the halt was announced
lots of democrats on social media were
once again claiming that pro-lifers are
not really pro-life if they won't stick
up for guys like john ramirez
so here's one example this is a tweet
from a guy named dan green who is he's
he's the national communications
director
for something called democrats for life
these are democrats who actually
consider themselves to be pro-life
and yet they
remain in the democratic party
which is which is
it's like calling yourself a satanist
for jesus it doesn't make any sense at
all
but um this apparently is a group that
exists and probably has about five
people in it here's what he tweeted he
said within a week of an abortion ban in
texas going into effect governor abbott
is killing john ramirez on death row
tonight
the last request of john for his pastor
to hold him as he dies that request was
denied
none of this makes sense we need a
consistent life ethic
uh i agree we need a consistent life
ethic
let me tell you what the consistent
ethic is
and it's actually very simple
it is always
wrong
always immoral and should always be
illegal
to directly and intentionally destroy
innocent human life
you need all of those
qualifications
all of those qualifications are
important
uh i mean obviously we can't say it's
always wrong to destroy human life
period because that would mean that you
can't even the self-defense is wrong you
can't shoot if someone breaks in your
house tries to shoot you in the head you
can't defend yourself
that would mean that all all war all war
is bad every single war that's ever been
fought on every side was was wrong
um and that doesn't make any sense
so that's why you need these kind of
qualifications you also directly and
intentionally is an important part of
this too
um
you know every time you get into a
vehicle
there's the chance that you could in
indirectly and unintentionally kill
someone
even
being sober you could still just by
driving down the road
someone could run out in front of your
car and you could kill them
you're driving down the road someone
runs in front of your car you
accidentally kill them are you a
murderer now should you go to jail of
course not
so that's why the pro-life
ethic needs all of those qualifications
they're very important
what about john ramirez
well what did he do to get himself on
death row
he stabbed a convenience store clerk to
death 29 times stabbed 29 times and
killed him
and stole a dollar and 25 cents
so this is a man who who butchered
another man stabbed him 29 times
for less than two dollars
now what i would say to
uh dan green and any other democrat
who advances this talking point but i
say you're pro-life but you
you're in favor of capital punishment
if you can find an unborn baby who's
guilty of stabbing someone 29 times and
killing them
then maybe this comparison will begin to
make sense
but i don't think you're gonna find that
because all unborn babies are
by definition innocent
they've done nothing they haven't harmed
anyone
they are the most
innocent human beings
on the planet
they haven't had the opportunity to to
make any bad choices or to intentionally
harm anybody
so
that's the difference
you know this
comparison
like acting like you can't like you
don't see any substantive difference
between a baby
and a murderer who stabbed someone to
death 29 times
i'm not sure i even believe it i'm not
sure that i believe that you don't see
the difference
and this is another example where it
actually works the other way just like
the bodily autonomy argument
you know that works for vaccines it
doesn't work it actually works against
the pro-abortion side
because what about the bodily autonomy
of the unborn baby who you're destroying
so with this when the the democrats
raise the you know the supposed pro-life
hypocrisy on capital punishment the
hypocrisy goes the other way
they're the ones who have a
contradiction that they need to explain
you know it doesn't trouble me at all to
say
that
i am not in favor of executing babies in
the womb
but i
am in favor of executing convicted
murderers that's my position
for a lot of pro-life people not all
that's our position
but for most democrats
uh their position is
the only people that they're in favor of
executing are unborn babies
they're saying don't execute the
criminal but execute the unborn baby
so who
whose position is more inconsistent
which which position needs
uh
needs further justification and
explanation
the position that we should only execute
convicted murderers or the position that
we should only execute unborn babies
all right this is from the new york post
it says a woman who claims she was
booted from a plane because her stomach
was showing says that she was actually
discriminated against for being a fat
tattooed mixed-raced woman
fairbanks alaska resident raelynn howard
33 alleges she was harassed by alaska
airlines staffers on friday in turn she
did what people do these days to state
her case she took to tiktok to post a
now viral video
originally shared via her fat trophy
wife account on friday
the clip has um
speaking of a contradiction in terms the
clip has since racked up 1.3 million
views and more than 180 000 likes as a
monday morning in the footage howard can
be seen getting escorted off of a flight
by police officers who proceeded to
question her about the incident
she said quote throughout my life as a
fat person i've had to deal with fat
phobia especially growing up in the
midwest but not to this degree
um she said i felt like i was being
discriminated against for being a fat
tattooed mixed race woman which in turn
left me full of emotions like anger
disappointment helplessness humiliation
and confusion
okay now she recorded her conversation
with i think it was the tsa officer
which apparently that
that's something they'll let you do well
they let her do it anyway she pulled out
her phone she's sitting in the room
just talking to the tsa officer
pulls out her phone starts recording and
um here's how that conversation went
so so what happened on the on the
i was harassed about my outfit okay
i put my shirt back on
so you did have it off yeah
i have this on sports bra
they asked me to put my shirt on
put the shirt back on and then they
approached me again
saying that i can't wear this
my stomach is showing and it's
inappropriate
and i said i'm covered up i'm fine
and she just kept going and i said
if you're gonna kick me off like then
kick me off i've done what you've asked
me to do
i want you to leave me alone
that was the third time they approached
me okay about my outfit
about wearing this outfit yeah
okay so she was she was wearing her
her bra on the plane just her bra
she she boarded the plane in her
underwear
and then was shocked when they uh asked
her to get off of the plane
get off the plane why i'm just sitting
here in my underwear
this is this is a fat phobia she says
can we go back i mean
we've got all these rules on the plane
already
um
and you have to wear the damn mask
and everything else
here's one rule that i would actually be
in favor of let's let us let's let us
take the stupid masks off
but um
a rule that i'd be in favor of if if the
airlines chose to impose it would be a
a much stricter i mean they have dress
codes but how many a much stricter one
if i was in fa if i was running an
airline
i think i'd go back you you think about
like the 1960s and 70s
they used to dress they used to wear
their sunday's best to get on an
airplane
which kind of makes sense because it's
it's an event
right you're you're flying through the
sky this is this is a you know it should
be a great event in your life no matter
how often you do it
that you're able to
traveled you know 35 000 feet in the sky
we become so jaded and
you know cynical about it we're so used
to it that we don't stop to think of how
incredible it is
so it actually makes sense and the other
reason it makes sense to to dress more
formally on a plane
is because you're
you're locked in this metal tube with
other people
and so you should make even more of an
effort to be presentable
yeah it's probably true
no one else on the plane wants to look
at you in your underwear you can you can
call that fat phobia all you want call
what you want
but they shouldn't have to be locked in
a plane with you for three and a half
hours in this small condensed area
so let's go back to that
for doing all the rules anyway how about
you have to dress for
certainly no no sports bras
um but also
no pajamas
okay
no flip-flops
i shouldn't have to sit here on the
plane with you an inch from me and i got
to stare at your hairy feet the entire
time that's not okay either
no flip-flops
you know make formal formal attires what
should be required on plans
in my opinion all right cnn is very
upset about the voter id law in texas
that just went into effect this week
and here is uh cnn
they say just in texas republican
governor greg abbott has signed into law
a bill that bans 24-hour and
drive-through voting imposes new hurdles
on mail-in ballots and empowers partisan
poll watchers and then they they list
again what the bill does and so here's
and this we're supposed to be upset
about this they're listing it because
this this is supposed to be something
that we find outrageous
okay again bans 24 hour and drive
through voting
new vote by mail id mandates
bans officials from mailing unsolicited
mail and ballot applications
empowers poll watchers
new requirements for assisting voters
monthly voter roll checks
all of that makes a lot of sense to me
what what part of that is a problem
and when it comes to the id
once again we got to go back to the
contradictions here
it's it's supposed to be
some kind of
oppressive
impossible requirement
to tell people that they have to get an
id
to vote you know once every four years
or once every two years of the vote in
the midterms
to tell someone that hey if you want to
vote in the next presidential election
you got four years
three years at this point you have three
years to to get an id and figure that
out and um and here
on the day of voting here are the rules
that we're putting in place
pretty
very very simple and easy rules
and that's supposed to be
impossible for people
we're actually excluding people from
voting just by putting those rules in
place
and yet it's not
oppressive it's not um
onerous to tell people that they have to
go to to make an appointment go to
walgreens get a drug injected into them
in order to even have a job
and hey by the way do you do you need uh
an id
to get the the vaccine i'm pretty sure
you do
especially if they're gonna if they're
giving you a vaccine card and you're
getting the vaccine passport they need
to know who you are and you're going to
have to be able to verify who you are
so
you can require an id for the vaccine
and then require the vaccine just to
just to go to your job every day
or you have to get tested once a week to
go to your job
but if you have to have that same exact
id to go vote three years from now
that's a problem
obviously it makes no sense at all okay
one other clip i want to play before we
get uh
before we move on to
reading the youtube comments this is uh
you know you know we love playing the uh
tick tock videos hit here
and this is a fun one um
because we have you know the crazy tick
tock videos the rant videos people in
their car
this is another
fun category of tick tock video because
this is the fictional story telling
genre of tick-tock videos let's listen
you guys we just got him from the park
you're not going to believe what
happened as i was about to leave so
everybody's playing in the mulch pit
while she's playing in there she made
friends with a little boy he's black who
cares they're happy i'm not thinking
anything of it this other mom comes and
sits down on the bench next to me the
mom is white she says to me oh my gosh
is that your daughter she's so cute i
said yep she then leans in closer to me
and goes you know she's playing with a
black boy
i was like
and
and then she was like oh no reason
there's just a lot of kids here and i'm
surprised that's who she's playing with
why is that surprising to you it gets
worse i was like she can play with
whoever she wants we're not racist she
says i'm not racist either she says her
biggest hope is one day her
grandchildren grow up to look kind of
like her that's your biggest hope for
your daughter
i you know what
of all of the things that have happened
in the world
that one
certainly is in the category of things
that happen i i i believe that i believe
every part of that story okay i i know i
started by saying this as a fictional
storytelling genre i should not have
said that
that story sounded
very credible to me i don't know about
you
haven't we all had these experiences on
playgrounds
are you just sitting there and some
racist white person comes up says what
all these black children doing on the
playground get out of here
haven't we all experienced that
oh no i mean literally none of us ever
have
it just never happens at all
can you at least
put
put some effort into your into your fake
stories
you know sit down do a little
storyboarding
give a little a little bit of nuance and
character and flavor to these to these
uh to these fake racists that you're
making up
give them a little bit of a backstory i
don't know
if you want us to believe it
but this just goes to show once again
when we get these these racism hoax
hoaxes which this certainly is
um the the good thing the good sign is
that these people are making up these
stories
have never met a racist person
so they have no idea what a racist
person sounds like or what what's a
what's a what's a credible story you
could tell about a racist person
they've never met one so they have no
idea and they're getting this all from
from movies that's that's a good thing
it shows how uncommon racism actually is
in this country
much the chagrin of uh people like
that woman in the tick tock video
this episode is brought to you by the
jordan harbinger show you want a podcast
to add to your rotation one that's
entertaining informative and packed with
actionable content that's what the
jordan harbinger show is all about it's
a top shelf podcast named best of apple
in 2018 so don't just ignore my
suggestion to listen to this one like
you probably do
with your with your friends who tell you
about podcasts no this is one you
actually really need to check out jordan
dives into the minds of fascinating
people from athletes authors and
scientists to ceos political activists
and government officials harbinger has
an undeniable talent for getting his
guests to share never been heard before
stories and thought-provoking insights
without fail he pulls out tactical bits
of wisdom in each episode all with the
noble cause
to make you a more informed
critical thinker to better operate in
today's society and that's why you
should be listening to the jordan
harbinger show and not
the one that you're listening to right
now point blank jordan harbinger is
smart funny and easy to listen to unlike
the matt wall show you can't go wrong
with adding jordan harbinger show to
your rotation it's incredibly
interesting there's never a dull show
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h r b as in boy i n is it nancy g
e r on apple podcast spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts
all right moving on to reading the
youtube comments this is from jabari
says
you guys ever wonder what matt's wife
thinks of the sweet daddy walsh title
i mean on the one hand it's weird but on
the other his wife
likes ridiculing him well she does but i
can tell you right now she is
i think i've already shared with you
the very distressing and troubling fact
that my wife is not a member of the
sweet baby gang
i've invited her into the gang
i've said hey
honey come be a part of the gang
she does she just she just laughs at me
and she says here's the word that she's
used so many times with a sweet baby
gang
uh creepy
if you can believe it
if you can believe it my wife thinks
that it's creepy for strangers to be
calling me sweet daddy
i don't understand it
women i mean it's it's impossible to
understand
uh nathan says matt i was very
disappointed when i tried the discount
code sbg
um and sweet baby gang and still had to
pay forty dollars for this t-shirt you
filthy greedy capitals is it really
forty dollars is that much it costs
why
is it actually forty dollars
um look
it it we're starting to cult here okay
and this is part of it it's it's
expensive on the ground floor
you think it's gonna be that's that's
cheap compared to scientology you can
walk into scientology building
and get to square one
of becoming a scientologist for just 40
bucks
i think that's a deep discount
when you think about it
um hey let's see william says robert e
lee was a highly respected military
officer before during and after the war
by both cultures of north and south he
was not a secessionist in fact when he
offered the position of general over all
armies north in the north by lincoln
lee's daughter reported how distressed
and sleepless lee was in making the
decision over the period of two weeks
lee also expressed his desire to see an
end to slavery yet has become his face
that is the poster of slavery in america
the absolute hubris and ignorance of
these people tearing down statues is
astounding
yeah that's like what we talked about
yesterday especially when it comes to
somebody like robert e lee
um
people refuse to view that
to view him or anyone at that period
within the context of their time
i mean
you have to keep in mind
it's
the mid-19th century
which means
that nobody
on the planet
has racial views that would be
acceptable to us
today nobody
that goes for the abolitionist that goes
for uh for abraham lincoln who famously
was in favor of
shipping all the slaves
back to africa who famously said that uh
that he's not in favor of racial
equality between the races
it's not just white people in america
either you go across the entire world
nobody at that period of time would have
had racial views
that would seem
acceptable
to us today in the year 2021.
never mind their views on so many other
topics
um like gender for example
so that's that's one part of the context
important context
again that doesn't that's the point of
the context is not to say
that objectively evil things were not
evil this is not moral relativism
slavery was still a great evil
it was a great evil when it in america
was a great evil across the globe and as
it was practiced across the globe for a
thousand years it was always evil
that's not the point the point is is
about
um understanding context
and also if we're trying to and this is
really impossible to do but and this is
up to god to do but if we're trying to
after the fact assess
the personal moral culpability of any
individual
that's when things like historical
context come into play
so that's part of the context the other
part of context as you point out william
is that
he was from
virginia that was his home
again hard for us to understand this or
see it this way as modern americans
but back in those days especially in the
south
their they thought of you know their
country was their state they considered
you were from virginia you consider
yourself a virginian first
that's not a wrong way of looking at
it's just a different way of looking at
that's how they saw it
um
so this was his home
his worst his family lives where his
sons lived
he was given the opportunity to
you know lead the armies
um to lead the army
in the north
but he knew that he would be marching
against his own home
and taking up arms against his own
family and probably his own sons
maybe we can at least understand how
that's like an agonizing decision for a
person to make
and then you when you put them you
squarely within the context of mid 19th
century america
is it really that hard to understand how
a person would make the decision to
fight alongside their families
rather than against them
but no as historical context is uh is
not allowed at all as we've discovered
well as you are aware if you've been
following the news or if you just
listened to the first part of the show
joe biden announced yesterday that he is
weaponizing the federal agency osha to
force all companies with over 100
employees to either mandate vaccines or
test their employees for covet at least
once per week i think it goes without
saying that this is one of the most
tyrannical overreaches of government
power americans have ever seen companies
that don't comply will face up to
fourteen thousand dollars per violation
could be ruminous for businesses all
over the country including the daily
wire so
we plan on fighting joe biden's
dictatorial mandate with every resource
at our disposal like i said at the start
this is a time for non-compliance for
drawing a line and saying no and that's
what we're doing at the daily wire as we
prepare for a battle of epic proportions
we're calling on all who are listening
to help us fight this obscene and
tyrannical mandate if you join us as a
daily wire member right now we'll be
you'll be giving us the resources we
need to take this all the way to the
supreme court if necessary you can be
part of something that's really
important and special go to
delhiwire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off
americans have been far too willing to
see their freedoms in the name of public
health that has to stop now we have to
stop complying go to daily wire slash
subscribe
do not comply for 25 off also this
weekend we remember the men and women
who lost their lives uh 20 years ago in
the most brutal terror attack america
has ever seen in an extremely important
episode of ben shapiro's sunday special
he sits down with one of the politicians
that shouldered much of the burden
placed on the bush administration in the
aftermath that was former secretary of
state condoleezza rice she was an
excellent and moving guest guest and
it's available now if you haven't had a
chance to check it out yet you should
definitely do that so go stream it now
at dailywire.com on the daily wire apple
tv or roku app or on ben's youtube
channel ben shapiro daily wire members
get access to special content on uh
bonus content from sunday special
episodes so you don't want to miss out
on that either if you join daily wire
today and remember use that coupon that
code that we just talked about do not
comply and finally
in a few days i will unveil the new
sweet baby gang anthem but for now
you can grab the official sweet baby
gang shirt that represents its spirit as
expected they're selling out fast so
click the link in the description to go
order yours today
it is a masterpiece
and a limited design this is i think one
of the
one of the great artistic achievements
probably certainly in the history of of
modern western civilization which maybe
isn't saying much is uh is the the sweet
baby game t-shirt so if you're an og
sweet baby uh you're gonna want to snag
one but if you're if you're a new member
of the cult slash gang then you also
want to get one so go now and order
your
t-shirt today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know i had this experience this past
week and perhaps you can relate i had a
the house to myself
uh because my wife and kids were out of
town for a couple days
and i had deliberated over it for a
little while and decided exactly how i
wanted to spend my free time that night
and my plan it was an exciting plan it
was this i was going to pour a glass of
whiskey i was going to sit in our
comfortable leather chair and i was
going to read a book and that's what i
was going to do with my time that was my
whole plan and for dinner i was feeling
a little bit adventurous so i decided
instead of ordering my customary general
sews chicken from the local chinese
place i was going to order another dish
from the local chinese place along with
the general sews
uh but then when it came time to order i
kind of chickened out and i ended up
just getting two of the general chickens
which was which was way too much food by
the way for one person to eat
anyway that was about all the excitement
that i thought i could handle so after
eating way too much food and reading and
drinking whiskey i figured i'd get to
bed at a reasonable hour say 10 30. that
again was the plan now i realized that
for younger people
everything i'm saying right now sounds
horrifically depressing
you can't believe that you'll ever be as
boring as me that like i have a night to
myself and this is what i wanted to do
but everybody in their mid-30s or older
hears my agenda for the night and thinks
wow that does sound like a lovely
evening and it would have indeed been
lovely
if i had stuck to the plan
but instead
after i ordered my food
i got to looking at my phone
and after my phone had cannibalized you
know you pick up your phone you start
looking at it and next thing you know
it's an hour and a half later
after it cannibalized the portion of the
night i decided that well i'm too tired
to read so i better just watch something
instead but then i started browsing
through the options and there are way
too many options and i just wasted
another portion of my time trying to
find something to watch finally i
decided to watch you know the same
episode of the office at the office that
i've already seen 95 times that i
watched a couple more episodes and i
went to bed
what could have been a relaxing but but
mentally and spiritually enriching night
had been in the end like so many nights
before it
sacrificed on the altar of the glowing
screen
what did i get in exchange for this
trade
did i get
an enjoyable night well that would be
something but it's hard to say that
aimlessly scrolling your phone or
mindlessly
flipping through the options on netflix
is enjoyable you know it's hard to say
that there's real joy to be found
in watching some kind of content simply
because it is content i certainly didn't
gain edification or enrichment of any
kind
um i'm not even sure that i could say
that i gained relaxation relaxation was
the night that i had already planned but
then abandoned
so i say all this as kind of a way to
lead up to this study in the sun which
was just released finding that the
average adult will spend 100 days of
their life
deciding what tv show or movie to watch
it's a hundred days cumulatively will be
spent
you know just
clicking through the options on netflix
that's the cumulative amount of time it
doesn't count all the thousands of hours
spent actually watching whatever you
eventually select now i'm always a
little bit skeptical of studies that
purport to tell you ahead of time how
many hours you'll spend of your life
doing this or that but 100 days in this
case seems about right
because there are other statistics too
some of them are a little bit more
familiar to us
and they kind of put the problem into
greater perspective according to some of
the most recent tabulations that i've
read
americans spend about two and a half
hours a day just on social media
the average time spent watching tv is
about four or five hours
overall then you gotta factor in video
games movies
porn for a lot of people american adults
stare at screens for 10 hours a day
10 hours
which does not sound like an
exaggeration it sounds
anything maybe an underestimate
for kids under 12 it's about four to six
hours a day again sounds like an
underestimate if anything
when you consider that the average adult
sleeps for seven or eight hours a night
that leaves only about six hours of
waking time not spent staring at screens
our lives have become completely
consumed by these devices the entirety
of our existence just about has been
condensed down into these little boxes
like the one that i'm looking at right
now
and that you're looking at
now people have been have been sounding
the alarm about exorbitant screen time
for years for decades really
before the internet existed there were
people warning that our lives have
become dominated by screens by tv
screens in that case
and we're so used to hearing these
warnings that we tend to shrug them off
in fact oftentimes we look at the people
who were panicking over
tv decades ago and we laugh at them like
they were chicken little so we say see
who are you guys so worried about
everything turned out fine
but it didn't turn out fine and we do
the same thing with people like in the
50s who were warning about pop culture
and pop music and rock music and where
that would lead
and now we look at them and we say look
at this
it's so quaint and ridiculous they were
worried about elvis
well no but they were right look at pop
culture today they were exactly right
with tvs the same thing you know it
didn't turn out fine they were right
more right than they knew they saw the
pattern but probably didn't expect that
within just a few years the average
american would spend nearly every waking
hour of every day looking at a screen
and the physical effects of this are are
significant all of this screen time
leads to obesity neck and back problems
sleep problems inability to focus
depression anxiety
on and on and on
we live in a world of fat misshapen
hunchbacks thanks largely to screens
and yet
the physical ramifications are not the
most disturbing aspect of this
not even the depression or the anxiety
that comes from a life lived inside this
box the most disturbing thing is what
drives us to constantly stare at the box
in the first place
as i said at the beginning
it's not really enjoyment or edification
i mean that might be the reason why you
watch one particular thing like this
show for example that's a good thing to
watch
but what is it that drives us to stare
constantly at screens as a default even
when there's nothing worth staring at
even when we're not really enjoying it
what drives you to sit there
in front of your tv and like search
desperately for something there's not
even anything you feel like watching
you're trying to find something anything
to watch
why would we spend all that time
searching desperately for just some kind
of content to consume it's one thing if
there's a particular piece of content
you know you want and you want it for a
particular reason and you seek it out
and you watch it but why are we always
seeking content why is there this
overriding impulse to keep looking
i think the main thing people seek from
the screen
is stupefication
it's sort of a mental numbing agent
an escape from
thought
we become reliant on the screens because
for us it's too taxing to think and to
reflect and to develop a real and
authentic interior life
the internet and the screens have become
a replacement for our interior life
that's why people reflexively just put
all of their lives on the internet all
of their thoughts and pictures and
everything they just throw it all out
there on the internet
whereas in the past they would have
stored many of those things inside
themselves because their interior life
was located within their minds but now
it's all on the internet um
we've become reliant on the screens
because it's
better than
it's a replacement for that
and maybe it's too scary also to think
that's why we become a nation of zombies
i think it's one of the reasons why
kovid has hit us so hard psychologically
we have been hiding behind the screens
for so long shrinking away from
difficult thoughts not reflecting on
anything really especially not thoughts
about mortality until something rushed
on to the scene that our screens
wouldn't hide us from
so
what am i canceling
i guess i'm canceling your phone and
your tv
and all of your screens
and all of you and also me
except this show that's that's not this
is a good thing to watch
or or any daily wire content of course
that's all
different so we will end this on that
inspiring note of blatant and
self-serving
hypocrisy
just another reason why i am also
canceled in this particular cancellation
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening go out
this weekend and do something other than
look at your screens
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin